hey leute und willkommen zu einem
weiteren redstone tutorial heute zeige
ich euch wie ihr ganz einfach eine clock
in minecraft erstellt dabei dem letzten
video einige fragen aufgekommen sind
viel spaß
ja meine lieben freunde nun befinden wir
uns hier in der gewohnten tutorial welt
sag ich mal die einfach aus einer fetten
wüste besteht die alten tutorial rampen
teile die ich da gemacht habe also dass
dispenser tutorial habe ich wieder
kaputt gemacht und nun zeige ich euch
mal wie ihr eine clock baut die ich bei
diesem dispenser tutorial außerdem auch
in einer etwas abgewandelten form
verwendet habe ich benutze heute den
skin von agent 197 der allerdings
ziemlich blau ist aber minecraft hat
wieder probleme mit den skin anzeigen
von daher seht ihr mich jetzt einfach
mal so im default skin aber auf jeden
fall finde ich den skin von ihm ganz
cool und tut mir leid dass ich dich
richtig verwenden konnte also ich zeig
euch mal für ein fach wie ihr ganz
schnell einen baum könnt ihr macht
einfach zwei löcher packt ihr einen ski
pisten hin das ist ganz ganz wichtig
darunter eine redstone fackel und hier
einfach einen kreislauf der das ganze
miteinander verbindet nun kehrt die
auswahl dieses diese fackel sendet das
signal an diesen kreis welcher in diesem
letzten kreis welcher wiederum zu testen
geht und wenn ihr nun hier ein brand
eins transline geht's richtig ab wenn
wir irgend einem blog frank setzt der
moment da ist kein fehler irgendwie
zeigt er den blog nicht anerkannt hier
könnte ein blog brandsätzen wie irre
lustig seid ihr könnt ja irgendeinen
blog rand setzen das sieht ein bisschen
komisch aus weil das im slapshot in
seiner back ist und zwar wartet moment
ich hoffe dass man eben mit einem
anderen block vielleicht sieht das dann
besser aus vorhin einer testphase was
nicht zu moment aber es funktioniert auf
den vergleich ja damit kann ich jetzt
zeigen und zwar indem irgendeinem blog
der western leitet jetzt auch wieder weg
war es egal jedenfalls funktioniert das
ganze so da ihr da eine redstone fackel
hat die zeit stoppt dass wir endlich
stoppt das mal kurz so da ihr hier
einfach eine das einfach ignorieren da
ihr hier eine redstone fackel habt wird
dieser pisten ausgefahren da diese
redstone fackel ja mit diesem redstone
kreise verbunden ist und wenn ihr nun
hier einen blog habt dann kapstädter
dieses signal
ich kann ich das ja mal dass bürger sie
haben quasi hier in block und der cup
dann dieses komplette signal hier und
dadurch wird das dann der pisten wieder
zurück gefahren aber dadurch dass dann
das signal wieder funktioniert sage ich
mal ist er dann wieder da das ganze
könnt ihr dann zb auf verbinden mit
einem dispenser irgendwie in der nähe
hinstellt wo ihr das tag an an dem tag
angehört das sei dann immer items
fliegen oder er könnte auch noch eine
weitere pisten dran stellen und moment
warten ist es tritt moment irgendwie
sowas bauen das ist jetzt einfach
provisorisch irgendwie sowas komisches
also das wird halt einfach immer weiter
geleitet durch dieses signal hier und
ich brauch ich das noch mal ganz kurz
auf weil das war bisher relativ kurz
also zwei löcher einfach ganz dicke
pisten hier eine redstone fackel und
einfach hier einen kleinen kreis rum
bauen einfach da einen block dann packen
und dann habt ihr schon nicht irritieren
lassen dass der block da manchmal
verschwindet also dass jetzt eine ganz
einfache redstone klopp die ihr so baut
und dann würde ich sagen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat würde ich mich auf
jeden fall über den daumen hoch freuen
beim letzten video habt ihr seid ihr
richtig abgegangen mit den daumen hoch
geben ich würde mich freuen wenn wir
dieses video vielleicht 800 daumen hoch
schaffen dass wir auf jeden fall genial
daher zeigt er mir dass euch das gefällt
was ich jetzt zur zeit mache und ich
will einfach sagen wenn ihr wollt dass
ich vielleicht im nächsten video euren
skin anziehe dann schreibt mir doch
einfach in die kommentare und dann bin
ich jetzt hier erstmal raus ich hoffe
ihr habt das verstanden und ich wünsche
euch noch ein wundervollen tag